con 15 votos a favor y 1 en contra la
corte internacional de justicia rechazó
este viernes las objeciones presentadas
por mianmar contra la denuncia de gambia
de presunto genocidio de la minoría
musulmana rohingya y se declaró
competente para el caso gambia presentó
la denuncia en noviembre de 2019
alegando que el trato de mianmar a los
rohingyas violó la convención de la onu
de
1948 que reconoce al genocidio como
delito perseguible por el derecho
internacional esto luego de que el
fiscal general de ese país visitará un
campo de refugiados rohingyas en
bangladesh y evidenciará violaciones a
los derechos humanos
de todos los estados miembros de la
convención sobre el genocidio tienen por
lo tanto un interés común en garantizar
la prevención represión y sanción de
genocidio comprometiéndose a cumplir las
obligaciones contenidas en la convención
financia
ya en 2017 una misión de investigación
de la onu había concluido que una
campaña militar de mianmar geo a 730 mil
miembros de esta comunidad musulmana a
bangladesh donde se habrían cometido
actos genocidas además denunciaron que
los rohingyas fueron confinados por más
de una década en un campamento con
condiciones precarias y sin acceso a la
ciudadanía y el libre movimiento en
mianmar y las reacciones ante la
decisión de las seis jota no se hicieron
esperar
este es un evento importante para las
víctimas que ven la esperanza de que se
les haga justicia y que los
perpetradores el ejército de mi amar
rinda cuentas ahora el tribunal
procederá a investigar el fondo del caso
un proceso que podría tomar años